[Music]
[Music]
as you can see we are here live at the
world premiere this is gonna be such a
huge night it's so huge in fact that I
needed some help with me it's of course
I've got many streets here doing every
night doing mini I'm doing great man you
streets from I Heart Radio we're here at
the world premiere on Hollywood
Boulevard I mean this is crazy the fans
are there the press is there the
Batmobiles here we had I started the
show screaming myself but that's because
the fans have been here waiting for
hours they've been screaming the whole
time that we've been here were fans of
the property as well so ever I'm so
excited to be here we're gonna be
talking to the entire cast we've got the
Justice League they're gonna be right
here on this stage and if that wasn't
enough you guys we want to make sure
that this is super interactive because
it's always about the fans right all
these cameras are going to be
interactive so if you're on Facebook
live of course tell them that they can
watch like four different scenes and
also pick their own right yeah actually
if you're on the Justice League movie
page then you can pick from different
screens on your computer you can do the
same thing on the DC all-access app so
we've got you covered as you guys can
see right there of course we are in the
main camera right now but you've got the
arrivals which i think is the show there
might be some barrel action going on
guys your
it's a moment of the awesome this year
because we've got so many cameras to
keep you all covered so while that's
going on I'm gonna leave you to it
you're gonna do all the interviews right
here on the main stage I'm going to go
to my own little area which is in the
fans in the heat of the area and I'm
just gonna have some fun cuz that's what
it's all about right here that justice
we got right it's gonna be a great night
I'll see you down there and like we were
saying there's just so much stuff going
on the carpet that we needed to make
sure that he's covering the other end of
it but I wanted to give you guys a
little tour of what it feels like when
you get on this carpet if you were a
member of the Justice League so come on
over here with me as you guys can see in
that other camera right over here is
where the limos pull up we got to see
the flash Barry Allen get out of the car
of course there's fans lining the street
on the other side as well they go right
over here come up say hello to the fans
and make their way of course onto our
awesome stage where hopefully I get to
have some great chat time with the
justice leaguers and now I'm gonna bring
you guys on down the carpet right here
this is what I like to call fan alley
there's so many fans like 300 fans here
guys are you excited to be here yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
in their cosplay we've got Wonder Woman
Superman what else we got Batman over
there there's so much great that you
guys look great 300 banjos all come out
to surprise and be so excited about the
Justice League are you pumped nice we've
got the Clark Kent won't open the shirt
for Superman yes we are getting glimpses
of some of the Justice League members
that are gonna be making their way down
this carpet so after they make their way
through all of the fans of course you
make your way down here to the Batmobile
and as I've said you know you can pull
up in the invisible jet or in the
Batmobile
hang out here and they're gonna pick
their way down this line as well where
we interviewed you guys can watch that
on TV online on the internet I'm sure
you'll be able to find all that stuff as
well but of course you're watching the
watch right here with us past the back
wheel and we make our way right down
here this is my area to Mr Man is right
here Justice League world premiere it's
crazy TIFF I love that the fans already
they're all in costume they got some
hats they got pins they've got
everything that they need for tonight
and also I think some limos are coming
up right so true but also we're saying
super fun to be here we want to make
sure that all of you guys at home
wearing so make sure you are using that
hashtag jl world premiere because that
stuff is going to actually end up in the
live show so if you're having a fan
viewing event that's right make it your
doing videos because you're watching
live with us little thing ever that's
there yes those videos that's right yeah
make sure you hashtag and like we said
you guys we want to keep giving you new
awesome great stuff because why not I
mean you've got something special for
them right now
exactly
now check out a very special clip we've
got invested Lee
we need you maybe you need us
[Music]
how do you know your team is strong
strong man and strong as alone never
heard that it's not a saying that's the
opposite of what the saying
[Music]
this is the only way
five of us
United
Oh awesome as a bad signal that's your
sorry your signal that means we have to
go now yeah it's so cool
[Applause]
[Music]
right now we are here I sprinted my way
down the red carpet I like to think that
I tapped into you know the Speed Force
to get myself here quickly it's absolute
craziness here on the carpet there are
so many Sam you guys can see them all
back there and they've been waiting
because they want to see their members
of the Justice League and what has been
so cool for me being a fan and getting
to work with DC and Warner Brothers I've
gotten to go to so many plays with them
I was actually just in London with the
cash for the press tour so it's just
been a cool journey to see where they
came from comic-con when we first
started seeing clips to getting here now
the press towards all of its greats up
to tonight where the fans have been
lining up waiting it to see this movie
which all of you guys can see in
theaters on November 17th I know you
probably already got your tickets
because I know I did I just got all my
friends together we all got tickets
already it will for sure be talked to
all of the members of the Justice League
Ben Affleck Ezra Miller Jason Momoa gal
gadot I have such a great experience
here in LA for the world premiere of
Wonder Woman that I'm so excited to have
her come back here on the carpet and the
great thing about the Justice League and
DC superhero films and characters and
that it brings out so many cool
interesting people you never know who's
going to show their face right here on
the carpet because they're just a fan of
Batman or Superman or the flash or
cyborg and I think that's one of the
cool things too about this movie is that
of course these are some characters that
we haven't met yet we're really gonna
get to see more from cyborg and flash
and Aquaman obviously leading up to some
of those stand-alone films which I know
I am so so pumped for and none of these
movies would happen if we didn't have
the awesome fantastic teams working on
the movies like the producers of course
right now joining us we've got Chuck
Rovin coming up here he's taken some
photos over there with some friends
tonight Rebecca Romijn over there as
well they're so excited to be here I
mean this is their this is their night
as well as all of the actors he's gonna
be up here in just one second like I
said you guys this is live you never
know what's gonna happen you can see all
of the fans that are lined up waiting
and soon as anybody starts walking you
can hear the screaming the cheering
right now I am joined by producer Chuck
gropin how you doing Joe pretty good how
you doing I'm so excited to be here I
got here tonight and the fans have just
been waiting all day longer I'm sure
some of them how does it feel for you
tonight to be here and actually get to
experience this with the fan you know
it's been a long journey and an exciting
one and you know but it's finally here
it's finally arrived and we're really
happy to be bringing it to the fans and
we think that they're gonna have a good
time there's so many moments as a fan
when you just get to see the teaser
trailer to the full trailer to the
second trailer just being able to see it
in the theater was there a moment for
you that when you finally saw it on film
you were just like I can't believe I get
to do this well you know I've been
having a good time with DC in the DC
Universe for quite some time so but to
have the whole league together it's you
know it's just different because it's
just like wow you know and I've been a
DC fan since I was a little kid
so it's definitely as a powerful
impression and since this is the first
night for so many people seeing this
movie what's the biggest thing that you
hope people walk away from feeling or
thinking that it was worth the wait I
hope that they feel that they had a
great time seeing how they came together
that they were surprised that they loved
the spectacle but that they got into the
characters and it was a great ride and I
feel like any time you see a superhero
movie they gotta leave doing one of the
poses so for me I'm like I always do the
Wonder Woman pose so I'm sure there's
gonna be some new ones that come out of
this one well each one of them have
their own particular style and that's
what makes each one of them really fun
to watch and fun to see them interact
with each other so I think I'm hopeful
that people will will pick the ones that
they hope they like them all but they'll
still pick their favorites and then you
know sort of network it's like picking
your favorite kid it's way too hard to
pick a favorite member of the Justice
League there are some fans here that for
sure have picked their favorites
Manny's down there hanging out with some
of them let's toss it down there thank
you so much Charles Roven joining us
tonight enjoy your evening good to see
thanks chef right here with melis Joe
who played Linda Park on the TV show the
flash hello welcome
Oh Manny you too are you ready for the
Justice League movie like more than
ready good so who are you excited to see
tonight I know Jason Momoa is gonna be
here gal gadot everybody's gonna yes my
gosh gal gadot is like my woman crushed
forever so if I see her I'm just gonna
be speechless if you could be a Justice
League member I mean you were kind of on
the flash yes who would you be in the
next film if there was a next film there
was a next film I mean it'd be cool if
they brought Linda Park to the big
screen huh
all right melis thank you so much for
stopping by we got Tiffany back over
there on the main stage hello hello you
guys we are back down here at the
beginning of the car but every minute
you never know who's gonna come up here
and as you can hear and see
trailers everything music is such a big
part of these films so right now I am
joined by Gary Clark jr. how you doing
sir this is a huge deal how are you
doing tonight I'm good thank you
so the biggest thing I think when the
music came out when everybody heard come
together it was such a surprise but it
seemed like it fit so perfectly well was
it about the song that you just felt
like yeah this is it I didn't know what
I was getting into it's kind of secret
so I knew it's gonna be a part of
something big and I heard a couple of
rumors about it and I was like you know
if it's anything like I think it's gonna
be this song is gonna be incredible and
I worked with a junkie XL on the project
and he laid it down for me as soon as I
heard it I knew was gonna do something
big something what is it about the
Justice League and DC superhero
characters that you like so much I mean
I just saw the new Wonder Woman and it
was so incredible so true and I think
the greatest thing you know is you
associate with a certain character you
want to have a superhero alter ego for
you guys if you had a song that is your
go to to like channel your inner
superhero what is it for you something
that I have to go to to channel my inner
superhero
I can't think of anything other would
come together really it's good it's good
how about you
I didn't the best thing that came to
mind was x-ray vision I like it I like
that's definitely a superhero power
thank you guys so much for joining me
and thank you for the awesome use like
enjoy the evening
bye guys alright you guys I think we
might be having a member of the Justice
League
joining us in just a second oh I think
he's up here how are you doing sir Ezra
Miller you look amazing okay so I was
talking earlier just saying how it's
been such a long journey from you know
seeing the trailers and the teasers
Comic Con to the press tour to being
here tonight what does it feel like for
you to be here overwhelmingly amazing
what else could you possibly say it's so
cool oh it's so cool so thankful I'm so
happy to be here so excited for more
people to see the movie I just love it
because every time I've seen you along
the way is where you have so much energy
you're so excited about the property
itself in general what is it about these
characters that you connect with so much
I think it's the idea that and so and
they break the rules you know I like
that superheroes break the rules they
break the rules of physics but then I
like anyone who breaks the rules and and
someone who breaks the rules and then
puts it to good purpose help save the
world
that's exactly you've got to break the
rules to save the world so true and I
love your earrings quartz crystals
dangling from your ears
yes you know I was gonna say that I am
distracted I'm give the world without
those you can't crystals on your ear
they could be pieces of kryptonite to
power a ship you never know you know
that there's a real crystal that is the
same chemical compound as what they
wrote in the Richard Donner's Superman
for kryptonite so it's actually called
kryptonite look this up it's a real
thing real crystal called kryptonite
it's not green though spoiler alert this
is why he is the perfect Barry Allen
because you actually know that
information I pray you're right
I I think you are and I gotta ask you
there's so many fun moments even just in
the trailers alone not even counting the
whole film that were so funny how much
of that was improv we're gonna improv
dancing while we finish this there was a
lot there was a lot of improv I
improvised every day and every scene
it's it was just a good way to work in
this character and it's something that
thankfully I was allowed to do and it's
a joy I mean I got to ie even I
consulted I went back and I consulted
with the woman who taught me
improvisational comedy when I was like
12 years old a woman named Rebecca
Drysdale whose amazing an amazing comedy
writer and so I got to sort of delve
back into that which was kind of the
only acting training I ever did was
improv and so I love when something is
conducive to that sort of work it's so
much fun and when you have other players
who can bounce off of you like all the
members of this pass and who can
accommodate for you maybe not saying the
line is you know make up for you just
going off is really great and I have
directors who support you in doing it is
a is a blessing well I know that the
fans myself included are super excited
to see this movie tonight what's the
last thing you just kind of want to say
to the fans to camera oh I just can't
wait for you to see the film I really
think you're gonna like it I really pray
you're gonna like it
we've worked very hard and I really love
it
particularly comic book fans I'm I'm my
prayers or that you will you will see in
this film what I see yes let us all that
is all I have to say I'm very happy I'm
a happy man fish I was waiting for you
to tap into the Speed Force and just
like disappear real quick but it didn't
it maybe another time yeah you know this
before scan I don't want to short out
your cameras and it can cause electrical
disturbance it can't be caught on camera
I'm not it's a
it's a little unwieldy so I don't want
to you know I don't want to break the
wrong rules it's true okay well we'll
believe that for a second
thank you so much as I enjoy your night
good to see you oh good
all right you guys like I said there's
so much stuff going on here on the
carpet every minute someone new is
showing up you can see their signings
going on with the fans on the street up
and down the street and then of course
the fan alley as well I'm trying to see
these over there actually doing signing
right now such a good night and every
minute there's new people coming up onto
this stage that are a massive part of
the DC Warner Brothers family right now
I'm so excited to be joined by Diane
Lane how are you doing actually thank
you I'm so excited to be here in general
this whole evening but to have you up
here and chat about this come a little
bit how are you feeling I'm thrilled
it's been fun watching this red carpet
grow all day because I've been peeking
out a window up the street to keep an
eye on it it's so fun to see everybody
be excited and get together and wave and
cheer and exciting what does it like
these evenings because obviously this is
not your first time being at one of
these big premieres it's not but it's
always new I mean it's always exciting
and thrilling and this film has so much
support and so many fans and another
whole generation of fans and I'm going
back I'm edgy at this point but that's
like a badge in itself to be like I am
oh gee and I was at the very beginning
of all of it it's true but yeah I saw
the film so I get to watch it again
tonight and now I can look for the
Easter eggs because I'm still learning
what that is so wait do you have a
certain scene or something that someone
told you to look for Easter eggs
I just need to keep my eyes peeled and
I'll get an education I love it what am
i I got to see the movie and one of my
favorite moments are some of the like
small moments between your character and
Lois Lane how much fun was it for you to
come back and work with Amy on this one
and what are those moments like for you
guys you know so much has transpired
since our previous time working together
and I'm so thrilled for her in her
career and all the different endeavors
that she's embarking on as it producer
and so you know it's been fun to catch
up on a personal / professional level
behind the scenes and then you know when
we're on camera together it's fun to get
to watch it later but I remembering all
this stuff it was it filmed well I love
those moments and I'm so excited for the
fans to see them as well thank you so
much for coming tonight and enjoy your
evening thank you I plan on it
thanks for being here all right you guys
I am here at the top of the carpet Manny
is manning the carpet a little further
down I'm gonna talk to him and see
what's going on that's right I'm waiting
for Ezra Miller to make his way down
here he's right now in the fan hallway
and I should say on the red carpet right
here Justice League premiere people are
taking pictures melesa gel of course was
on the flash played Linda Park we've got
the Batmobile
Mario Lopez of course on the red carpet
as well and we've got tons of people
just lining up because they're signing
autographs
they're in the limos they're trying to
make their way right here down the red
carpet we've got the press and we've got
Tiffany of course on the main stage so
all right so oh they're chanting they're
chanting I want to be in that chance I'm
gonna go check in at the fan area as
soon as I could get down there and make
my way oh that says right he's right in
there premiere if you guys want to see
all the and why'd you go up they talked
back ago I'm going I'm going I'm going
here we go here we go we're going we're
going to the fan area I'm going as
Americans over here look at him the
flash the flash with the flash that is
bananas Kid Flash
I always think of pictures with Wonder
Woman right now look
insane and crazy that is alright
tiffany-smith you take it back over
because I'm going to touch this room
illa right now Manny is so excited and I
am so excited to be down here on the
carpet because I get to talk with the
man who basically is the creator of the
recreator of cyborg the great of cyborg
and the rig creator of Victor the
creator of both personas really when you
think about it I created them both in
one way or another yes I'm so excited to
have you here and just talk about this
movie in general what is it about this
character in particular that really drew
you in I think the beauty of cyborg is
that he sort of in my mind represents
the other that unlike all of the other
superheroes he has no alias he has to be
himself 24/7 and he has to be able to
accept who he is so it's kind of like
being black in the world you have to
accept who you are all the time and
can't hide from it so as to deal with it
and I think it's it's a wonderful
metaphor for this movie and getting to
do this film obviously cyborg is a
character that so much of it was CG and
stuff that happened after the fact what
are you hoping to see the most on the
big screen is this your first time
seeing it tonight absolutely I want to
see the whole thing I mean I could I
can't wait to see the film absolutely
are there things for you growing up were
you a big comic book fan I wasn't really
know I mean I you know I was kind of I
read a couple Superman books and you
know the Batman stuff but it wasn't a
big comic book for a person what is it
about this world that you think keeps
people coming back over and over again
it's absolute escapism I mean you know I
mean it's the good guys about the bad
guys and the good guys always win
so it it's a very moral society
especially in in today's world I think
we need this kind of sugar the world
that we live in is very dark very sort
of suspicious all the time so to have
this kind of wonderful jubilant film
it's just great
well I think just hearing you talk about
that fans who may recognize you from
some of your other work you live in a
world that is not very moral so how much
fun is it for you to kind of get to play
in both of those it's terrific I mean
because it's you know it's it's fantasy
you know I mean the very first day I was
on this movie somebody put me in a
harness and flew me over a wall
you know it was just it was just a lot
of fun so it's unlike doing something
like scandal which is very dark and and
and very much the real world this is
fantasy and it's you know it's like a
big costume Halloween party I always
like asking too because there's always
someone in your life that is like the
biggest comic book fan of all time who
was the person who was the most excited
when they heard you were gonna play this
role probably my son I mean I think he
was very excited about the fact that was
gonna be in this movie I don't get a
chance to do these kind of movies very
often lately do something very heavy so
he was very excited awesome well thank
you so much for joining us enjoy your
evening
earn some extra dad points thank you so
much nice to see you you as well guys
this is so much fun we've got to talk to
a lot of people already and so many so
many more are coming behind me you can
see they're getting their photos taken
just like I showed you when I walked the
carpet limos are pulling up there's one
pulling up right now who knows who's
gonna be in it over there as well you
can see Ezra is taking photos with all
of the fans it's another thing about
this cast that's so incredible is they
love the fans they definitely take the
time to say hello to them pop over take
some pictures or make their way onto the
stage this is such a cool night you guys
and make sure if you are watching that
you're using the hashtag jl world
premiere i think they're about to get
over here to the carpet where I'm joined
by somebody right now he was here to
dance around of course women oh oh who's
here oh I think that this is mr. ray
Fisher how you doing sir how you doing
good good here I'm gonna have you come
right on over here so I want to make
sure the vans though are you sir the
energy hello hello everybody good to see
you thank you for being with us here
tonight
is Justice League it's such a momentous
occasion I wish you all here I hear a
spirit but guess what they are here
watching live with us and I was just
telling them make sure that you - like
JL world premiere because their videos
and tweets and all that good stuff might
end up in the street the jail will
premiere Bourg life everything use it
all there's never too many hashtag
there's number too few hashtags is yours
well make sure you use that board life
though if you want him to see it right
absolutely what does it feel like for
you tonight to be here after this
journey of comic-con
Fred's tours tonight is the premiere
here in Hollywood tonight is the
premiere honestly there's no feeling
like it in the world I mean you could
see the energy you can feel the energy
even do you can physically see it is it
something you feel you see it physically
I am you know it's been a long road with
this one we've had a lot of ups
obviously we you know we've had some
downs too but you know we're here we're
finally here the Justice League is
making it to the big screen this is my
childhood come to life I was gonna say I
know that you are a huge comic book fan
so what were some of the stories that
you read that you really tapped into to
figure out who Victor cyborg was for you
I drew a lot a lot of inspiration from
the original version of cyborg from the
New Teen Titans by George Perez and Marv
Wolfman from 1980s you know cyborg in
their iteration who's super deep is such
a super deep character you're dealing
with the loss of his body the loss of
his mother you know so many things just
so many things that were so great to
play with as an actor you know I'm
rebuilding him you know that to me was
number one yeah this makes me so excited
this is one of the reasons why I love
doing these carpets is because I get to
feel the excitement in the energy from
you guys is there a particular moment on
the set that gave you this I'm sure it
was probably been more than this well
was there a particular moment on set
honestly there was never a dull moment
as far as I was concerned I mean between
Zack and Israa and Jason and Ben and
Gulf just just the the the the the funny
energy on set honestly there was never a
dull moment particularly favorite moment
of mine was we'd have a lot of kids come
on set Jason will bring his kids example
bring their kids and you know a cyborg
we'd have the cybernetic light and the
cybernetic and the cybernetic chess
piece and there's a little remote that
would be able to use to turn it on and
so any kid that was on set we were
rolling the camera we'd let them turn on
the cyborg chess piece and the eyepiece
and then make them feel as if they were
part of the production and so they say
okay turn on the cyborg liked on the
side board light and as soon as they
turn it on I'd pretend to like come to
life as cyborg it was pretty special you
say as if I were cyborg but you are
cyborg that's true that's true ready no
matter
my battery so I love it so much there's
such great stuff that comes out of these
superheroes and that you guys are a part
of that onset and offset is so great is
there anything that you finally just
want to say to the fans right into the
camera go for it I want to say thank you
thank you thank you thank you for
believing in us this is this is the
culmination of all your faith all of our
efforts and we would not be here without
you
hashtag Gordon why this is so much fun
you guys I'm gonna pass it over to Mandy
cuz I know there's some great stuff
going on down the carpet so what's going
on over there mani I am in the fan area
Ezra Miller just passed by me I was
trying to get a handshake
I got Wonder Woman I got Batman Batgirl
I got Superman I've got everybody I got
the flash over here this is what's going
down in the fan area they take their
pictures they get handshakes they get
hugs my man little flash kid flash what
up how you doing King did you have fun
Ezra Miller gave you a hug and you took
a picture yeah I loved it you two right
one I took a picture any sign it now
that is what I'm talking about right
here
the fans Jill go bananas right here at
the Justice League premiere so if you
want all the action of course hashtag jl
world premiere don't forget you guys
when you guys are taking those pictures
put that up there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right we're gonna go back
to tiffany-smith at the main stage thank
you so much Manny right now I am being
joined by Danny Elfman how are you doing
sir great I am so excited that you're
here tonight to talk with us about this
project specifically because obviously
you're no stranger to this world to the
dark nights world to Batman's will talk
to me a little bit about what it was
like working on this project in
particular it was just so fun it was
kind of like coming home to like old
friends and and really it was just
delicious it really fun in fact I can't
remember when I've had so much fun in
years what is it about these characters
in this world that really helps you or
allows you to play a little bit more
yeah you know it's just I guess whatever
it is that's attracted people to these
characters since we were kids and I
don't know what that is I mean I was
once a kid picking up Superman and
Batman comics at a little local
newsstand you know on the way off my bus
I'd get off the bus and there would be
the new ones and it's like what
attracted me then what attracts me now
magic I don't know well and it was
really fun because I got to talk with
some of the cast at the press conference
I was just asking them about what music
they would go to to channel their
characters you know and I asked Ben and
Ben said he was like well I just I can't
not talk about Danny and the music that
he did for the film and just hearing it
and how much emotions come up what is
that like for you when you hear it the
actors playing these roles that there's
and grossed in the music as you are it
makes me feel really happy thank you for
telling me you made my night oh my gosh
I'm like that's that's the smallest
thing you have made so many DC fans
nights every night they go through this
movie because of the music that's
incorporated in this thank you from for
me it was just simply an honor and a
pleasure and I know that that sounds
really phony but in this case absolutely
the two words that are absolutely
accurate I have to ask because I think
you work so much in the music world for
you if you want to channel your own
inner superhero what music do you go to
like I listen to my own stuff obviously
I don't listen to my own stuff ever
I never listened to anything I've ever
done once I'm done with it I never
listen to it again what I've been
maniacal about that since since day one
I can't listen to my own stuff unless I
have to
you'll work on a project do the film and
then listen to it that one time and
you're like and done yeah if I listen to
it later all I'll think about is how I
could have made it better or different
so I just don't do it well we're happy
that for this one you got to come back
and do a little more rehashing of some
sounds that we've heard before which are
just warming my heart I just love it so
much thank you so much for coming out
tonight
really enjoy your evening and all of you
guys watching
don't go anywhere we're gonna be right
back make sure you're using that hashtag
jl world premiere see in a minute
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a stranger
from the sea
[Music]
also known as the Aquaman
and you can talk to fish
man he kills from two different worlds
he's half man he's half and Lansing
is the heir to the throne of Atlantis
ladies might be king
and he finds his place at the Justice
League yes when he can really put his
skills to use
my favorite things to film is when I
jumped on Batmobile
I was like we cannot believe sir for the
battle good now
to do this together
just like a bat I dig it
[Music]
[Music]
we are live right here at the Justice
League world premiere and of course JK
Simmons taking pictures right there on
the red carpet in front of all the press
we've got ray Fisher down the line over
here getting in an interview with Mario
Lopez lots of people lots of press lots
of things going on all the celebrities
of course lining up around here
Tiffany's got the main stage covered and
of course all the limos are lining up
and we can't wait for the next person to
come up we got Joe Martin here right
next to me he's about to come up
hopefully hopefully I get to talk to him
or maybe even take a selfie all you got
to do is hashtag jl world premiere if
you go out if you guys want to see all
the action right now on Facebook of
course then of course Justice League
movie you guys gotta follow that on
Instagram on Twitter everything social
media don't forget to follow that right
there so if you guys want to see all the
action that's going on right now and
we're gonna show you a really cool cool
video right here exclusively just for
you and the fans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's right see JK Simmons is right
there that was kind of cool a nice
little haul video so all you gotta do is
if you guys are watching right now and
you guys are actually here some people
are here they're trying to stream it on
their phones
hashtag JL world-premiere you're gonna
get all the action right now oh my gosh
I just heard I I just heard somebody
just the ride right now Oh Joe Martin hi
doser oh you like that guy don't you
briefly big muscles he looks like he
does doesn't it well thank you so much
for coming around here right here live
at the Justice League world premiere I
think Tiffany is going to go get Jason
Momoa right now go for it
that's right just more Aquaman himself
all right - hey guys I am down here at
the very beginning of this crazy awesome
fun red carpet at the world premiere of
Justice League it has been such a crazy
night already and I know it's just gonna
keep coming because we've only talked to
a you know we haven't talked to the
entire Justice League yet and we're
gonna keep getting more and more of them
showing up on the carpet which I think
just a couple minutes ago mr. Jason
Momoa Arthur curry up woman showed up
here if you could hear on the livestream
everyone was screaming and cheering
that's kind of when you know one of the
leaders has shown up here on the carpet
and you guys I want to see how you would
react if you got to see one of them
showing up on the street walking the
carpet make sure you're sending us
videos pictures using that hashtag jl
world premiere and if you guys are
watching this on the Justice League page
or in the DC all-access app we've got
you completely covered we've got cameras
all up and down the carpet which as you
can see right now we've got one oh my
god
right now I am being drugged so do you
sir hi doing proper hugging now I think
everybody could hear you before they saw
you how are you doing sir I'm awesome I
am four years in the making of stoked
what I was gonna say how does it feel
from going from BBS where people got to
have a little glimpse of this character
to now even more yeah yeah I'm BBS I'm
was like hey guys I'm here to support
everyone I'm not really in it now I'm
like I'm in it now you show up on the
carpet like you just all about me
exactly exactly it's so great because I
think these movies we do get introduced
to these characters in small ways this
one we get to see even more of Arthur
what is it about this okay bring your up
here bring her up here this is live you
guys you never know what's gonna happen
Jason Momoa is coming up here hello how
are you doing you how does it feel being
here with him tonight wonderful it's
been a journey from the first time that
he found out he was gonna play this
character to tonight it's actually
getting to work on the standalone film
as well has he gotten has he gotten more
and more excited has he gotten more and
more to know this character more and
more nervous cuz right when I showed up
I'm like I'm getting nervous baby
Sookie's are vulnerable superhero it's
true I think that that's the best thing
about these characters is that they're
just multi-dimensional is their
character that you really connected to
at any point in superhero female male
obviously I would say it's gonna
probably be Aquaman since he's right
behind you but I mean growing up or
right guru in the room either
I mean Ezra is fantastic yeah I mean
yeah
yes you know Ezra
he's otherworldly and hilarious yeah
there's so many great fun humorous
moments in this movie as well
Ezra obviously improved a lot but I feel
like we got a lot of those moments from
Aquaman as well who was the first person
to break on set I broke all the time
I mean Ezra's he's amazing and I would
constantly laugh so I mean it's very
challenging to be like the gruff face
guy when all you want to have fun with
your friends but and and and Ray would
never break great was like the hardest
to break which is why he is cyborg it's
perfect
he was sees all method I mean obviously
getting to be here tonight what is the
experience just been like I saw the fans
doing some signing over there this is
awesome it's I'm gonna go over there and
sign pictures and and talking to the
fans a little bit we got some questions
from the fans sent in Amelia Hertz asked
what was the funnest moment on set
during filming geez Louise there's so
many stress is what I want to look at it
that's what happens like I said to you
guys red carpet moments
we had another Atlantic Tyler come on up
here
come up here say hello to each other on
the carpet I'm gonna try and get Amber
Heard up here so we can talk - to
Atlanta and that one's I love this so
much you guys this is live you never
know who's going to show up you can feel
the energy just between the different
actors and then throw in all of the
energy from the fans here in Hollywood
it's absolutely incredible I'm so
excited to be a part of it I'm so
excited for all of you guys to be
getting to watch with us on the live
stream make sure your eyes are using the
hashtag Justice League make sure using
jl world premiere so we can see those
pictures we want to see our videos we
want to see your reactions to what I
experienced when Jason came up here I'm
gonna see if I can get them up here I'm
like do I interrupt Atlanteans I don't
have a weapon I don't have a trident or
anything to try and get them and they're
much taller than me wait can I have you
guys come on up here I'm like I've never
gotten to be on the stage yet with two
Atlanteans yet how are you doing amber
I'm great great what is it like for you
getting to be here tonight cuz I was
talking to Jason earlier I'm just saying
we got to get a little it's dance party
on the stage but he got to you know
experience this a little bit with bbs
this is may be your moment where you get
to experience the fans seeing you for
the first time did he give you any
advice Jason's advice
let me just say it's very specific and
I'm not going to blow his cover like it
stays under the sea stays in his land
oh man well I do have to say it being a
huge comic book fan these two characters
are one of my favorite couples because I
feel like they're both so strong no one
has to hide their identity what is it
about these two characters for both of
you guys that you're like this is an
awesome relationship and I want to play
this role they grow on each other they
have to prove each other's they see each
other's charm throughout I mean it's not
just like this instant
that's the surface they really you earn
each other's love and compassion and
trust and humor and it's not just it's
not one superhero it's not just the guy
rescuing the girl or the girl you know
being the superhero and that's her
moment it's actually a team and so a lot
more modern you know I mean it's like
there's very complex so confusing
layered there's gonna be a lot of ocean
puns I can feel it I can feel it Chris
fun fish puns are fish bun you gotta be
sweating me just keep them going
holy mackerel oh they're so great these
are gonna be the hashtags that people
are gonna be tweeting about all night if
this is just a little taste of what
we're gonna get into the Justice League
and in Aquaman in the future I know that
the fans are freaking out and super
excited about fun don't watch this movie
either of them everybody likes fun so
they're gonna go see it thank you guys
so much for coming up here chatting have
a great great evening
you guys both look stunning thank you so
much I'll take it
enjoy your night right
you guys this is live you never know
what's gonna happen you never know who's
gonna come up here on stage as you can
see we just had Atlantean royalty
leaving the stage absolutely awesome
this night has been so cool so far still
people are coming onto the carpet it's
packed I feel like that means that there
might be somebody there one of the
league members I don't know joining us
in just a minute I've gotten to talk
with so many of them throughout the
journey of getting to tonight that it's
so fun to have them here with all of the
fans you can see Jason was really really
excited to be here so far we've gotten
to talk to Aquaman we've talked to Mira
we've talked to the flash and I know
there's gonna be even more superheroes
that we're gonna get to talk to in a
couple minutes here I hope you guys are
having an amazing time with us here on
the livestream of the Justice League
premiere here in Hollywood
I'm Tiffany Smith and I am such a huge
DC fan but I'm always so excited to get
to be a part of this with all of you
guys and we want it to be super
interactive so make sure you're tweeting
telling us the moments that you guys
have loved along the way the moment that
you can't wait to see her what you're so
excited to see when the movie comes out
on November 17th I know I'll be singing
at multiple times tonight I will see it
again and I know I'm gonna find even
more moments that I love in this movie
and you guys like I said super
interactive tonight so if you're
watching on the Justice League page or
in the DC all-access app you can click
between a bunch of different cameras
that we've got covering the entire
carpet so if you want to watch four
screens at once
you totally can do that or if you want
to do kind of picture-in-picture just
tap on the screens along the side so
that you make sure you're not missing
any of the moments from the limo drop to
this stage right here where I am
standing to the fan alley where there's
300 fans some of them cosplayers as well
just waiting
see their favorite superheroes and at
the end of course there's tons of photos
and interviews I'm gonna stop talking
though because I think right now there's
somebody that you want to hear talk just
a little bit more than me because I
don't know if we're going to get to hear
I'm talking the movie or not right now I
am being joined by mr. Henry Cavill you
guys know him as I was way more excited
than you were in malat I'll be excited
about me yes I did it so you could have
joined me in it Hey yes
siga they didn't do it with you next
time I won't leave you hanging so I've
got to ask I think the biggest question
on every fans mind is is Superman in
this movie hmm
Superman is in this movie in a very real
concept and ideal he lives in the hearts
of the superheroes left behind and
that's all I can tell you sorry guys I
thought I would try I've gotten to talk
to you a couple times now about this
movie and I've tried different angles
different ways to try and get you to say
anything about this character in the
movie so I think the fans are just gonna
have to wait till the 17th to see it
which is super exciting right absolutely
yeah guys get out there see it I think
you're really gonna like it like a lot
what is it about this character because
we had Jason up here Diane Lane was up
here earlier just talking but she called
herself the og in this world which I'm
like you've been in it since the
beginning what is it what has it been
like for you along the way what's
changed from the first premiere to
tonight oh wow so much has changed I
mean what are we talking about because a
lot has changed it's been six seven
years in life huge amounts I've I've
grown I've changed a lot the characters
certainly changing and evolving
each step close to the coin books and
the world you feel like can you tell
that energy is different just from the
fans like even from the first film to
now having this team-up
absolutely yeah when it comes to team
ups like this is a huge huge deal so
everyone brought their best game tonight
and everyone's very very excited so
since we can't talk about any of the
scenes you may or may not be in the film
what was it like for you getting to see
some of the other actors just their
interactions together and building miss
Leigh an incredibly special time for me
I'm I'm a geek at heart like a genuine
geek and turning up on set starts
visiting the guys obviously and seeing
everyone dressed in all their regalia
and full outfits apart for cyborg as in
his pj's and it was a real geek out
moment genuine feeling of like holy moly
this is happening like this is really
happening we're really making Justice
League and all my favorite heroes are
right in front of me and the guys doing
such an amazing job putting this
together and you're gonna love the way
they have graced their characters they
are they are fantastic so what I love
too is that you guys have all kind of
created a bond we had Jason up here a
little while ago Amber Heard came up
everyone thought getting just chatting
I talked with Ben Affleck awhile ago and
asked what was one thing that you did
was the least like Superman and he said
he said sometime
Henry walks on his tippy-toes so I'm
gonna take this moment to let you say is
there anything about Ben that is so
unban you said that I think that's a
joke let's make her be the shortest guy
in the league that makes them it does
yeah goodness me then he gets very
sweaty in the cow so you like to take it
off and
sometimes he's vocal about it alright
that's a good one that's a good one
Batman's not usually that vocal so I
feel like that makes sense tonight so
excited to have you here one last thing
is there anything that you want to say
to the fans before they see this movie
soon wow what can I say
being a fan myself I was I was excited
to see this movie I'm excited to see it
again tonight you guys are gonna love it
go in there and enjoy the ride enjoy the
experience because you're gonna see your
favorite superheroes come to life I mean
I could read into what you just said
there that someone's favorite superhero
is Superman we'll have to wait and see
thank you so much Henry for coming on
joining us and congratulations see you
as well all right you guys I tried I
tried really hard to get anything out of
him we got a little bit baby
I don't know I'm gonna send it on down
to Manny right now he is Manning the
carpet chatting with some more people
this is the Justice League world
premiere it never stopped Manny what you
got that's right I've got mark McClure
who played officer Sadowski in the movie
how are you sir life is good life is
great
life is great I just saw Henry there
that's right he had the Superman curl he
did he looked just like Superman
he looks just I think he don't know oh
we don't know who you don't know how was
it like being in the movie with such an
amazing cast I mean you've got everybody
Mannis be Justice League well actually
it's a from Superman in the movie it's
been 40 years almost to the day where we
premiered it here in Hollywood and New
York and all over the place but this is
a star-studded cast this is you know
Hollywood's change Hollywood's gotten
bigger
stars and stars Christopher Reeve who
always longed for did he did he make
Superman and he's he's uh he made
himself a star which is very cool I mean
Henry Cavill he had the curveball on so
he embodies justice just like I can see
where the casting came in that may be a
natural thing and they looked at it and
said this guy just looks like Superman
get it that's right now how was it like
being in the movie when you got the call
to be the officer well the the situation
I'm standing here because of two people
Richard Donner and Jeff Jones
those two people have been together a
long time and they are the people that
actually believe that a man could fly
and it is so important that Jeff is
running the show now and it's so cool
and in the fact that he's kind of a
Donner kind of a he hung around Digg and
dick was such a believer and it's just
I'm so happy for the whole situation I
love the stories we're going back to
TIFF she's got somebody special on the
main stage thanks mark I am so excited
right now
we were just already chatting about some
of the cool moments it happened right
now I am joined by royalty again Queen
Hippolyta Connie how are you doing
tonight we are having so much fun
already this is so exciting and I I can
feel all the fans are out here I'm so
excited too so it's a lot of fun well
and I said earlier I was like I was
lucky enough to get to be here for the
world premiere of Wonder Woman and talk
with you guys what is it like from that
night to being here tonight for the
world premiere of Justice League you
know it's it's kind of wonderful to come
here tonight and see just how well
Wonder Woman did after all of that you
know it was at the time we didn't know
how it was going to be received we felt
we've done everything we could and and
so obviously there's a really good
feeling being here tonight reprising
some of these characters which was a lot
of fun to do and I'm excited to see all
my friends you know
we made friendships on this film and we
were filming Justice League and had a
lot of fun so I look forward to hanging
out with him tonight
I'm the thing that I love so much is
just kind of before we came over here we
were just chatting about how you guys
are such a family you guys are doing
things on and off set together right so
when we were on set and off set you know
we would take our kids Jason the night
took our kids to rock climbing because
there's something that Jason does a lot
and he introduced me and my little son
to it and just so much fun Henry too
though he doesn't have kids yet it's a
real champ with kids has a real gentle
wonderful way of talking to kids and
they love him back I feel like that's
the quality that Superman should have
right and I'm so excited because Justice
League in general you can't have the
league without having a formidable
villain for them to go up against
we've got Steppenwolf in this one so
what do you think it is about this
character in particular that makes it
such a great match for this movie you
know I barely know Steppenwolf because
all I saw and I still haven't seen the
film was you know a guy in like some
weird suit so that's all I know I've not
seen a CGI yet so I'm as excited as you
are to discover Steppenwolf well I love
it because all of these films always
have Easter eggs things that surprise
the fans and it's really fun to hear
that there's gonna be things that
surprise the actors in it as well thank
you so much for joining us all right you
guys we've got so much more great stuff
coming to you from the world premiere of
Justice League I am gonna have a video
for you guys in just a second this is an
interactive night we've got stuff coming
in from the fans so right now check out
this video from right here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I heard about you
didn't think you were real I realize
useful
it's really exciting to bring Batman
back to the big screen
I put her together team people with
special abilities stop right there I'm
in
I totally had a fan freakout moment I
cannot believe I'm standing next to
Batman for the first time understands
that he can't do this by yourself
mom this is the days where mom's biggest
concerns were exploding wind-up penguins
a simple life will be Justice League we
see the evolution of a new Batman
he's moved on from lone vigilante to
recruiter and leader
you get to enjoy the adventures of this
group as they saved world what are your
superpowers again I'm rich
recognize this well to recognize we just
have to save it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello you guys tiffany-smith here at the
world premiere of Justice League it's
been a crazy night I'm so excited that
you guys are hanging out with us here on
the livestream there's so much a great
stuff going on but we want to see stuff
from you guys at the fans so make sure
you are using at that hashtag jl world
premiere we already showed a little clip
earlier i think we had a little flash
dance we had a little cyborg walking
down the carpet from fans shooting it
here at the premiere but if you're
having you know a viewing party of this
livestream or if you and your friends
have cosplayed as the Justice League
anything like that make sure you send
them our way because they may end up
right here on the show tonight this is
so much fun the fans are all lining up
they've been here for hours days it was
so great Diane Lane when saying earlier
she was peaking out of her hotel room
window just seeing the fans grow and
grow and grow and grow and then getting
to off the carpet tonight feeling that
energy this carpet is so huge there's so
much stuff going on but of course we had
to have somebody else helping me out
here on the carpet and manny has been
hanging out down at the other end of fan
alley how you doing Manny I am here to
thank you so much I've got a tip look I
got Ludacris Chris Brigid bridges right
here
Kenny say can just wait right there
justice league notorious is what live
cars are like you know we had a support
superwoman because he was also in a
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Tiffany it is bananas right here we got
the limos pulling up with all the
celebrities great fishers over there
doing like the t-bone meal over there
right now on the red carpet Connie
Nielsen is over there
Amber Heard is not too far from me and
it is bananas down here on the red
carpet because now all all of all the
celebrities that you got earlier they're
now down there me so I can take a little
silly
yeah well the crazy thing is you can see
that it's just kind of they're all fans
and friends of each other as well so I
was up here and Mammoet up here and then
starts freaking out because amber herds
there and of course there's like a hug
session and then another actor shows up
and then everyone's talking to each
other so I can only imagine what the
energy is like down a little further on
the carpet where we've got multiple
members of the league you know what I
love is that Jason Momoa was ready to
party for the after party after the
movie he was dancing on your mainstage
he was he was he surprised me out of
nowhere I didn't I had heard he was
coming and then all of a sudden I hear
at the yelling in my ear and I'm like
yes that is our Aquaman and I love it I
love it so much the forever
speaking of screaming the fans have been
screaming all night Manny will you take
us down and show us some of those cool
fans in their costumes and stuff yes I'm
going down right now
Ezra Miller has stopped by jump in the
fan area as well as Jason Momoa Amber
Heard and Paula Henry Cavill he is
autographs right now look was where's
the camera right here he is signing
autographs I love this that the just
asleep is signing autographs for their
fans check it out I'm gonna do a quick
selfie as well because we are here and
we are living in the moment
hashtag jl world premiere there's Henry
right there look at that he's signing
something for me that is not theirs know
that is mine
oh wait he gave it to somebody else dang
it
Oh TIFF Oh TIFF oh look how all the
superheroes write their ticket pictures
the fan this fan has got the Clark can
look alike he's got the Supergirl right
there the flash I mean it is crazy right
here we've got to to suckle or I love it
you got a tutu on Wonder Woman too - I
love it right there
we got the flash that is what's going on
right now in the fan area I love that
he's taken everybody else's phone to
take selfies you don't even have to do
it yourself
Henry is doing selfies with everybody
else's phone look at that the flat the
Flash's taking a picture of Superman I
just love what we're doing right here
hashtag Dale world premiere don't forget
if you guys want to be interactive check
out all the other cameras that is going
on right now on the live stream on
Facebook on Instagram on Twitter
everything Justice League did he come
over here yet he did oh my gosh did you
get a picture
you missed but
there's there's more all right Tiffany
you take it away at the main stage
[Music]
I am really pumped to introduce the next
person coming up here
the fans were screaming I got to be here
for the premiere of this film and I know
she's gonna look absolutely stunning you
guys can see over there already saying
hello to Deborah Snyder this night has
been so wonderful I'll get it
Wonder Woman wonderful yeah I did it
it's fine I was practicing my puns just
like you know Jason and amber we're
doing I'm not quite to their level yet
but I'll keep working on it
as you guys could see behind me gal
gadot is here our Wonder Woman I'm so
excited to talk with her about this
movie because obviously we got to see
her in the big standalone and tonight is
the night that she is a part of the
league and obviously I can't wait to see
what else is coming from a Wonder Woman
she looks amazing I feel like it's
Channing a little bit of the lasso of
truth on her dress tonight being such a
huge fan of all of these characters but
specifically Wonder Woman it was such an
incredible experience to be at that
premiere and then tonight to be joined
by the woman herself it's a dance party
I love this how are you doing gal oh
good I'm catching my breath but I'm
really really good and this is so big
and amazing and I'm very excited how are
you I am so excited to be here tonight I
love seeing we've talked about the
Wardrobe styling many times and you're
like oh who are you channeling today I'm
like are you channeling a little bit of
the lasso of truth
yeah let's I'll take that I'm wearing
the last of version of the lasso of
truth about Cesaro I love it I love it
so much so talk to me a little bit about
this experience for you what it's been
like from getting a glimpse of Wonder
Woman in BVS to then obviously the
standalone to tonight being part of a
team it's it's amazing and it's great
and I'm so grateful that I get to work
with people that are so talented and I
really like and love working with
it just it just really really great it's
wonderful I already I already said that
when I was like we're about to be joined
by someone wonderful do you feel like
every time you say that's not you're
like these are puns I should stop I
always I never get sick of vents which I
should probably should but yeah I'm
always like oh you look so wonderful how
are you I'm wonderful thank okay so of
course I'm sure there's a little
wink-wink going on in at least your mind
as you're saying it but this is a live
stream we're getting comments from the
fans so much questions coming in they're
asking a lot they want to get a full
look at the dress can we can we get a
look at that one I feel like these are
always the most fun moments but also it
it makes
slam it up I feel like those moments
when you're shooting you know the
posters for these superheroes you have
to pose and channel that inner superhero
moments like this do you channel someone
different for the carpet honestly on the
carpet they usually close because it's
the fun part it's when there's no you
know there's no pressure of performing
right now and shooting scenes or it just
enjoy what we've already you know did
and and celebrate it because this is
what we're doing with celebrating the
movie tonight so yeah it's great I know
all the fans are celebrating as well
just one quick question from a fan what
is your favorite trait of your character
from epic prime what is your favorite
trait of your character personality
trait like what it was what
characteristics what characteristic does
Wonder Woman embody that you love so
much I like the combination of the
goodness but she's like wink wink witty
she can be like she gets she'd get the
point you get the joke and she's a
little sassy I like that about her well
we love getting to see that on the big
screen as you play this wonderful
character that we all love so much thank
you so great to see you as always enjoy
your evening thank you so much thank you
so do you you look wonderful
I'm gonna say it to everyone thank you
so much have a great night all right you
guys I'm gonna let her go float down the
carpet and enjoy her evening and pass it
over to Mannie but we'll be right back
make sure using that hashtag JL world
premiere
[Music]
what did you do this weekend ina nothing
very interesting
[Music]
and protector of the world
[Music]
who grew up isolated from the world of
men to super smart super sophisticated
full of hope she's the most talented
warrior
time doesn't care for the fame or for
the glory
she partners with Batman to unite the
need asking people we don't know to risk
their lives I know how this works
she's this to the team
she makes each and every one of them
feel stronger and
[Music]
they said the Age of Heroes will never
come again
[Music]
save the world a noun
we do this together
[Music]
right now you guys as you can see we
don't want you to miss out on a single
moment of the awesomeness here on the
carpet or off right off to the side of
the carpet where all the fans have been
lining up to see their favorite members
of the Justice League Ben Affleck mr.
Bruce Wayne / Batman is taking selfies
signing autographs they are as much fans
of these characters and properties as
all of us seeing them take the time to
go over there say hello to the fans who
I know are all eagerly awaiting to see
this movie on November 17th so you guys
I know that I'm sure there's people out
there who are actually tweeting us and
sending in pictures from those moments
right over there but if you're a home
make sure you're sending us photos send
me a selfie of your reaction just seeing
Ben Affleck over there or seeing gal
gadot up here and her awesome wonderful
puns cuz those are gonna be my new
favorite thing I'm gonna try and keep
coming up with as many as I can for
Aquaman for Wonder Woman we'll see what
I can come up with nobody wants to hear
that but I'm still trying Ben is still
over there signing this is downtown
Hollywood this is what a premiere is you
guys this is the world premiere of
Justice League we gave you a tour of the
carpet they pull up in their limo they
say hello to the fans over there make
their way up onto this stage to chat and
then they go down I like to call it fan
alley I think
that noise there's probably a good
possibility we might be being joined by
Batman soon I'm getting really excited
this has been such a wonderful evening
so if I did it I said wonderful again
this has been such a great night you
guys every moment that you're enjoying
use the hashtag jl world premiere and if
you want to see all the different
moments as you can see we cut from over
here at the limo drop to further down
the carpet in finale where a gal gadot
Wonder Woman is taking selfies maybe an
instant video I'm not sure but make sure
you guys are following all of the actors
social justice league as well so you
don't miss out on any of the fun going
on here or moving forward I had such a
great time with this path on the press
tour in London we got to check out the
Justice League experience they had rooms
that were decked out for each character
and it was just so much fun looking at
all of the small details which I know
comic book fans always do so make sure
you're looking for all those little
small details those Easter eggs when you
see justice league in theaters which
probably gonna take a couple times to
catch all of them I'm sure and as you
can see right now we've got two cameras
going gal is signing and taking photos
Ben was just in the corner doing it the
same thing as well this is our justice
league when I have moments like that
where I just get to say this is our
justice league it makes me think of
being a kid in reading these comic books
than just being able to be here tonight
with all of you guys watching I just
want to say a huge thank you for
everybody who's a fan of DC all-access
and following me along this journey
because I'm a fan just like all of you
guys so I peek out every time I get to
talk to them and just getting to be able
to announce and talk to members of the
Justice League is just bonkers honestly
so thank you guys all so much and make
sure like I said again use that hashtag
Jael world premiere to tell us about
maybe some of your first comic book
experiences some of your first moments
falling in love with the Justice League
like I did we are here in Hollywood this
is the place where the world premiere of
this leak is happening behind me there's
still so much craziness going on
Ben made his way I think he's act that
he might be making his way up here in
just a minute I might have just caught
him I think so I think so just a second
this is live you guys you never know
what's gonna happen and right now I
would like to welcome to the stage mr.
Ben Affleck how you doing sir
excellent how are you doing I am so good
and so excited to have you up here it's
been it's been a crazy night what is it
like for you being here tonight it's
just really you know this is like movies
like this are special they feel just
bigger and more spectacle and the fan
enthusiasm is so exciting you know it's
just a whole different thing it's it I
guess you feel a little bit like what it
might be like to go to a rock concert or
something and perform you know it's
really really fun there is something
just about when you guys pull up in the
limo and the fans start screaming what
is it like for you to go over there and
just see some of their faces where
they're just you know they're talking
about you but they're talking about this
character that you get to embody that
they grew up with well there's
definitely like an amount of humility
because you know so much of what's
exciting to fans is the history and
tradition of these characters and have
been that's been built on over and over
by so many talented people particularly
in the case of Batman you know where
you've had such directors and such great
actors playing it and it's a
double-edged sword
you know you get enthusiasm but you have
expectations I'm a little bit envious of
the of like you know like Jason you know
there's been no Aquaman so he's now just
the defining Aquaman but it's fun I mean
it's so great to see how into it people
are you know well and I think the great
part about all these characters is
there's so many small moments between
them I think you can't have a great
Batman or Bruce Wayne without a great
Alfred and some of my favorite moments
are just the interactions between the
two of you guys one scene in particular
you guys are flying away and Alfred is
just hanging out like what do you think
he does in his downtime when nobody's
there
I think he keeps himself busy I don't
know he's a Jeremy Irons just such a
great actor and somebody I've looked up
for such a long time and like the whole
rest of the cast I just had an
opportunity spent time people I really
liked
respects and that made the sort of fun
spirit of the movie really I think shows
through when you see it I think it
definitely doesn't you get to see new
aspects of some of the characters you
may already know I'm excited for the
fans to see what you bring to this film
is there anything you want to say to the
fans before I let you go into that crazy
fan alley the fans I would just say
thank you it's really it's a an honor
and a pleasure to carry the mantle of
this role and thank you for your support
awesome well thank you so much but enjoy
your evening nice good to see you enjoy
your night such a cool night you guys it
has been absolutely epic wonderful
incredible I can't think of many more
words to say because this has just been
insane thank you guys all so much for
joining us on the live stream we just
chatted right now with Batman Bruce
Wayne Ben Affleck joined us he's making
his way down fan alley as you can hear
there's fans that are cheering so
excited just to take a photo with him or
see him for a moment it's so great
because as I've said and as you guys
have seen the whole evening all of these
actors love the fans as much as we love
the characters that they get to play so
there have been so many signings going
on along the street so many photos being
taken so all of those things that are
happening here make sure you guys are
using that hashtag Jael world premiere
so if you can't be here in person with
us you can follow along on social media
right now though you guys I'm gonna just
pass around so you can see a little bit
more of everything that's going on on
the carpet but don't move because we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
before I was born he came as the
spearhead of an alien invasion
which made me feel
[Music]
Prius Emily's what is everyone
enemies coming from far away
[Music]
just like that you really are out of
your mind I'm not the one who brought a
pitchfork
[Applause]
[Music]
nice as well
we just have to save it
ride ain't over yet mom man rated pg-13
experienced an iMac
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is you guys just got a glimpse of
everything going on on the carpet if
you've been with us all night there has
been so many great moments like this one
right now we started the show together
now Manny is back down here at the start
of the carpet with me it's printed down
there I felt like I was the flash you
tap to get down here track just a little
bit it looks like a mile and it felt
like it so you know Jason Momoa is down
there right now taking the pictures
doing some press gal just is just left
the fan area it was bananas tonight
thank you guys so much for joining us
tonight if you did an amazing job
tonight thank you so did you if you had
to pick one favorite moment or a moment
that stood out to you on the carpet what
would it be for you gal touching my hand
saying hello that's all I needed
that's all I be was it wonderful it was
one there amazing I like it you took it
in a new direction it got a little bit
of a new spin to it I liked it what was
your favorite night oh man probably I
gotta say it was meeting two atlantean
yeah and it was the moment where Jason
Momoa and her we're saying hello to each
other my first time getting to see
Aquaman and Mira together cruise and
just the fun that they were having with
each other just it's one of those things
where you get a movie like this you fall
in love with the characters from the
comics or from the cartoons or whatever
it is you see these actors play these
roles and then getting to see where
they're gonna take them is so so excited
I'm like totally nerding out right now I
know that the Justice League we're like
family when they saw each other they
gave each other hugs absolutely it was
amazing Justice League oh my gosh thank
you guys so much
hashtag jl world premiere you guys want
to see all the action that happened
tonight and it was amazing I can't
complete I have nothing to complain
about either because this was epic make
sure you guys are using that hashtag jl
world premiere let us know how you felt
watching along with us comment let us
know what your favorite moments on the
carpet were who you who you're excited
to see on the big screen and the movie
comes out November 17th don't forget
don't forget to go get your tickets
because I already bought like three I'm
excited like don't forgive a good yeah I
yeah because you
I haven't seen a movie she has and I'm
I'm jealous right definitely get your
whole week together get everybody all in
get your tickets go see this movie on
the 17th thank you guys so much for
watching with us and don't move because
we've still got a little goodness coming
up for you right after this
I'm Tiffany Smith and I'll see you soon
on Manny's treats bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he knows
[Music]
Karthik
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he went on shoe shine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
me